when i first heard the idea of a
turntable ferry i assumed it was an
early design for anyone figuring out how
to do ferries properly
a modern cross river ferry is built with
a cabin at the side so cars can drive on
and drive off without having to
awkwardly reverse so i figured
a turntable ferry like this one is going
to be a prototype solution before anyone
figured out how to put the cabin at the
side instead of having the cars reverse
off you turn the whole car deck around
and yes that does happen here
but the real reason for the turntable is
more clever than that and there's only
one of them
left anywhere in the world here in
western scotland
over the sea to sky there's been a ferry
here
since the 1700s people say a vehicle
ferry certainly since the 1930s
this particular ferry has been here
since the 1980s
and it was operated by a man called
broadday mcleod
when the tolls were removed from the sky
bridge he felt probably
that you know the fed his time was up
really because you could get across the
bridge for nothing so who would pay to
go on the ferry so the local community
banded together and thought we can't
have this not having the ferry is a
social experiment we don't want to be
involved in
so a little group of folk got together
and saved the ferry
and brought it into community ownership
which it still is today
there is quite a strong current the
current can be up to nine knots
in the straight but that's exceptional
current and wind together can make
things
interesting the ferry is very seldom
pointing in the direction it's actually
going because of the wind and
because of the tide we often have to set
the boat going in a different direction
to allow us to get to where we want to
go the water here is
tidal and the current is fast simple
ferry designs are great
if you've got steady water that's always
at the same height your boat arrives
puts down a ramp to the shore and the
cars can drive on and off
but if the water's tidal well that ramp
could need to go three or four meters up
or down depending on the time of day
so the only way it works is if you build
infrastructure on the riverbanks
floating pontoons and large ramps that
give the cars enough room to drive up
and down
that's far too big and expensive for
somewhere like this so the obvious
solution is a slipway a boat ramp a long
gentle approach to the water in a lot of
places that does work
sail up to the water's edge drop a ramp
and everyone stays dry no matter the
water's height
but that means you need a long long slip
way
and importantly your boat needs to be
lined up straight
here in this narrow channel the current
can be so strong that isn't possible
even if you could line up straight
reliably you can only tie the boat off
at the front so
the back's probably going to swing out a
bit so what you want to do
is what a passenger ferry does pull up
alongside the slipway
and let people get off sideways great
for people not so useful for cars
and that's where the turntable comes in
the turntable is a remarkable
piece of victorian engineering it was
based on the old railway turntable
system
cars could come onto the boat from any
jetty
at any state of the tide to then be
turned around and be able to drive off
usually it's two but one person can turn
it a lot of oil and grease is expended
and
keeping it as smooth as we can the way
that the boat is designed
it draws virtually no draft at all
forward and it's only four and a half
feet
at the stern so it can come alongside in
very shallow water
that was the part of the design that
makes them so
versatile very very very rare indeed
that we can't work it would have to be
an exceptionally low tide
before the invention of the roll-on
roll-off ferry
these were the original roll-off rural
ferries
now there's been a bridge across the sky
north of here since 1995
so these days this is mostly used just
by locals and as a tourist attraction
this summer
but if you are in this area well i'd
recommend taking a diversion and
driving across this way because there's
only one place in the world
where you can drive off a turntable like
this
thank you very much
you